y no es poco el tema que lo trae a esta
mesa porque han habido muchísimos
titulares alrededor del aniversario de
la guerra y aquí los vamos a analizar y
a conversar con usted selensky por
ejemplo invita a Lula a kiev y busca su
ayuda para que Ucrania sea mejor
comprendida en América Latina y esto nos
Abre otro abanico de posibilidades
dentro de la guerra y es mirar hacia
este continente durante todo el día en
la prensa de todo el mundo últimos
minutos como acá también especiales
reportajes entrevistas sobre todo en
Europa pero también en América Latina
ahora estabas leyendo una portada del
diario o globo el principal diario de
Brasil la principal economía
latinoamericana en el que se ve esa
invitación de celestial Lula donde se ve
una nueva fase de la guerra donde
zelensky Busca ya nuevos apoyos también
en América Latina África como hemos
visto en los noticieros y ha utilizado
frases como Pues esta invitación de Lula
es una forma para que también en América
Latina entiendan mejor lo que está
pasando en Ucrania entiendan mejores a
disputa y entiendan mejor la invasión de
Rusia a Ucrania también zelens que ha
dicho que le gustaría participar en una
cumbre de Estados latinoamericanos no
sabe si va a poder venir hasta acá por
temas de seguridad pero es uno de sus
deseos esa invitación a los países de
América Latina ya que estas principales
economías tanto Brasil como México como
Colombia como Argentina como chile pues
han votado en contra de la invasión pero
sin embargo no se han unido a esos
bloques europeos occidentales con
Estados Unidos de enviar sanciones
económicas contra Rusia o armas en su
defecto a Ucrania sí que ha habido
respecto a esta invitación de zelensky
macron Emmanuel macron el presidente de
Francia en esa vía diplomática también
se ha querido unir y propuso una reunión
cuento globo en el artículo para esta
semana entre selensky entre Lula y
macron pero parece que Lula no está por
la labor él también está lanzando como
su propia propuesta de paz de esa
necesidad de que otros países que no
están involucrados en el conflicto
también participen en las de paz de
hecho hoy mismo ha tuiteado en un
momento en el que la humanidad necesita
la paz ha pasado un año de la guerra
entre Rusia y Ucrania es urgente que un
grupo de países no involucrados en el
conflicto asuma la responsabilidad de
impulsar una negociación para
restablecer la paz
Rafael pues justamente el presidente de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva es
prácticamente el último que llega hasta
condena por parte de Naciones Unidas a
la invasión aquí Qué papel puede llegar
a tener América Latina con este tipo de
invitaciones que está recibiendo por
parte del presidente Pero hay un punto
importante Brasil es parte de los brics
exactamente y por eso en este juego
tridimensional y eventualmente
transversal hay sinergias importantes en
distintos sectores que vinculan a Brasil
con Rusia y recordemos que dentro de los
países estratégicos de América Latina
fueron Fernández y bolsonaron los dos
líderes que Durante este año visita
directamente a Vladimir Putin en Moscú
se excusaron diciendo que esas Cumbres
se preparan con mucho tiempo de
antelación que sin duda alguna era muy
complicado
evitarlas o renunciar a ellas pero
también lo hubieran podido hacer huir
ese sido una un involucramiento América
Latina siempre ha buscado mantener un
papel distante Por qué distante Santiago
porque la relación si bien América
Latina ha favorecido históricamente
principios como la autodeterminación de
los pueblos como el respeto al derecho
internacional y en este caso Rusia ha
violado esos principios también es
cierto que no quieren tomar partida
asumo Porque el involucramiento de los
Estados Unidos y en particular de la
organización del tratado del Atlántico
Norte que históricamente ha sido una
reivindicación de los distintos países
por eliminarla por su innecesario papel
en El Siglo 21 pues no los pone en una
posición cómoda a muchos de ellos así
mismo si analizamos cada una de las 33 o
34 realidades de nos vamos a dar cuenta
de que exposiciones distintas una cosa
es los regímenes de Cuba Nicaragua y
Venezuela por ejemplo en los cuales ha
habido inversiones directas de
importantes empresas rusas de petróleo
de gas y de materiales preciosos y otros
que tienen una relaciones comerciales
más fluidas como es el caso de Brasil
como es el caso de México y como es el
caso de Argentina y otros que si bien no
gozan de un comercio significativamente
fluido pues han tenido relaciones
históricas diplomáticas relativamente
fuertes y que no estarían dispuestos a
apoyar a Estados Unidos y la otan que
que sería como se traduciría a nivel
interno o a nivel regional este tipo de
involucramiento recordemos que los
países de la región han sido muy
críticos de la intervención de Estados
Unidos en pasadas crisis Como por
ejemplo la lucha contra el terrorismo
México y chile votaron de manera
negativa al interior del Consejo en el
año 2003 cuando se propuso una
intervención sin que hubiera inspección
por parte de la agencia de la energía
atómica en Irak y ese hecho también
refleja de que nosotros No
necesariamente ni colectivamente porque
es difícil que que que
individualmente ni individualmente
vayamos a dar un apoyo decidido a De
hecho si usted lo mira cuando uno cuando
se realizó la organización de los
Estados Americanos hace pocos meses el
presidente intervino de manera virtual
pero también han sido reticentes porque
ojo selinsky llega ahí por una serie de
casualidades Y si bien ha encarnado en
este año un importante liderazgo para
mantener unidas su nación y para
demostrar que hay resistencia pues
también hay profundas dudas acerca de él
después de este conflicto No claro lo
cual es otro tema igual esto que está
diciendo lo vimos reflejado en la
reunión de asamblea de las Naciones
Unidas donde Nicaragua fue el único país
que votó no a la resolución condenando
la guerra donde Cuba se abstuvo donde El
Salvador se abstuvo de votar y Bueno hay
otro país Aquí que entra en juego Judith
Usted lo sabe muy bien y se trata de
México y este fallido plan de paz para
Ucrania y esto nos va a dar a los tres
Si queremos para hablar toda la noche
así titula El Milenio también uno de los
principales periódicos de México como
decías México y su fallido plan de paz
para Ucrania similar a lo que
comentábamos en esta primera portada de
globo amlo Andrés Manuel López Obrador
se situó asimilar a Lula en esa búsqueda
de un plan de un plan de paz para
Ucrania pero en este caso fue más
ignorado durante todo el conflicto
México ha ido cambiando un poco
distintos matices su posición respecto
al conflicto a condenado también ha
pasado por declararla no intervención y
la autodeterminación de los pueblos Y sí
que hubo ese acuerdo de paz que él
proponía de unos cinco años mínimo que
los analistas Ahora nos confirman a
Rafael También estuvo motivado por la
inflación esa subida de los precios de
los alimentos de la energía que también
ha afectado tanto a América Latina como
hemos estado diciendo durante todo el
día amlo proponía una comisión de
mediadores que incluía al Papa Francisco
también al Primer Ministro de la India
nadie entra modi y al secretario general
de las Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez
sin embargo Esto fue llevado el 16 de
septiembre a las Naciones Unidas y no se
le hizo mucho caso a al canciller
Marcelo ebrard por lo que finalmente en
un discurso en el Zócalo Andrés Manuel
López Obrador dijo lo siguiente habría
que empezar por preguntarnos si no se
pudo evitar la guerra y si la ONU y los
políticos de las principales potencias
no fallaron en la responsabilidad de
promover el diálogo Además creo que hay
que tener en cuenta dos cosas Una una es
las críticas que hacen Marcelo ebrard
jefe de la diplomacia mexicana y otra
muy distinta a la posición de amlo amlo
no ha condenado directamente las
acciones de Rusia quien lo hace
especialmente en los foros
multilaterales es el jefe de la
diplomacia Marcelo ebrard que es un
hombre fuerte obviamente y que sin duda
alguna ha buscado canales distintos para
buscar negociaciones pero tampoco ha
habido una condena directa del jefe de
estado obviamente la posición de México
es significativamente particular porque
tras de que no tiene una buena relación
o interlocución con los Estados Unidos
Pues tampoco se puede arriesgar a tener
una relación más fría con Washington por
lo tanto tiene que calibrar muy bien
entre los diplomático y lo político cabe
preguntarse también qué tanto tienen
directamente que jugar a los
latinoamericanos dentro de la guerra en
Ucrania Más allá de y aquí mi pregunta
pues para ustedes si es de esta
conquista de esta pelea entre Estados
Unidos y Rusia por tener cada vez más
presencia latinoamericana en un contexto
de guerra en un contexto de crisis de
suministros de inflación de subida de
los precios en las que se necesitan más
aliados Y además que esta es una guerra
evidentemente que se salió del terreno
de Ucrania y es completamente
geopolítica Bueno usted tiene una
pregunta muy interesante y es sin más es
mejor para resolver no estoy seguro en
efecto las consecuencias las hemos
tenido que sufrir todos como lo hemos
visto en los distintos especiales del
Canal desde los productores de plátano
en Ecuador hasta los que necesitan
insumos para el alimento en Uruguay y
así sustantivamente todos los países se
han visto significativamente afectados
yo no estoy seguro de que quieran
desempeñar un papel más activo porque
eso No necesariamente nos va a permitir
encontrar una solución No generamos
confianza América Latina sigue siendo
visto en múltiples foros como un una
región profundamente fragmentada que no
genera confianza y que tampoco tiene
unos interlocutores lo suficientemente
claros para saber
Y cómo pueden aportar en la solución las
ideas muy bien expuestas al interior de
las Naciones Unidas no fueron
necesariamente acogidas y se ha buscado
otros interlocutores en efecto
tradicionalmente los problemas o o los
conflictos entre Rusia y algunos países
pasan por solucionarse a través de la
mediación de Estambul más que de alguna
capital latinoamericana y yo paso a
preguntarle por otro actor importante de
la región Rafael y es Nicaragua que es
uno de estos siete países del mundo que
ha votado en contra de frenar la
invasión rusa a Ucrania hay varios
titulares al respecto de varios medios
lo citan nos centramos en la prensa en
el periódico nicaragüense que dice
Nicaragua uno de los únicos siete países
del mundo en contra de frenar la
invasión rusa Ucrania además de
Nicaragua son velarus Rusia Corea del
Norte Mali eritrea y Siria es curioso
Porque si bien Ahora ha rechazado esa
salida de Rusia de Ucrania el 24 de
marzo de 2022 un mes después de la
invasión Nicaragua votó en contra de la
invasión rusa sí que cambió la posición
el 12 de octubre de 2022 cuando ya votó
si a favor de esos cuatro referendos que
se hicieron en Rusia sobre terreno
ucraniano y Cabe destacar también Más
allá de Nicaragua como comentabas antes
solo ha habido en esta votación de que
tuvimos ayer jueves Bolivia El Salvador
y Cuba países de América Latina se han
abstenido A diferencia de las grandes
economías latinoamericanas por último
Cabe destacar también como Nicaragua
está en un momento también crítico
regional bastante alienado del resto de
estos países donde Bueno pues países
como chile o Colombia han hablado de
Dictadura para referirse al gobierno de
Daniel Ortega y Rosario Murillo Ay cabe
preguntarse para el análisis Rafael qué
tan estrechas esa relación entre
Nicaragua y Rusia o qué tanto Nicaragua
está tomando esta posición precisamente
por esa situación interna tan complicada
que está viviendo para marcar una
distancia de sus vecinos y de la
comunidad occidental simplemente para
aislarse un poco más así como señalamos
minutos antes que la ayuda militar ha
sido un respirador artificial para
Ucrania la ayuda militar la
investigación científica que se hace en
materia aeroespacial ha sido importante
para mantener a flote a el régimen de
Nicaragua por parte de la federación
rusa no es nuevo incluso desde la guerra
sandinista en la década en la década del
70 las armas rusas fueron las que
sirvieron a esa guerrilla para hacerse
con el poder por lo tanto si lo miramos
en perspectiva es un país muy pequeño
pero sin duda alguna la el juego
retórico y de apoyar una causa que
consideran ellos es noble pero que no
tiene una justificación ni jurídica ni
moral respecto al sufrimiento que han
infringido a Ucrania genera ruido
profundo en la región y uno dice acá qué
está pasando y con un elemento
interesante si ustedes se dan cuenta
el recuento que hacíamos de la votación
muestra como países de de izquierda como
Nicaragua Cuba pero también de derecha
como El Salvador terminaron
absteniéndose de esa situación lo cual
refleja que el trabajo
constante por parte de Rusia tal vez en
las últimas dos décadas en América
Latina si bien no es excesivamente
sobresaliente porque no hay un aumento
significativo de el volumen Pues sí ha
generado que en lo que se consideraba el
patio trasero de los Estados Unidos haya
una una fragmentación importante en el
sentido de que No necesariamente se vota
de manera unánime y firme para rechazar
al menos en la asamblea general de las
Naciones Unidas
a las acciones que ha llevado a cabo
Rusia pues le agradecemos por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en esta primera
parte del especial más adelante volvemos
para ver otras publicaciones alrededor
del mundo sobre este tema relacionado
con el aniversario la conmemoración
del inicio de la invasión rusa a Ucrania
tenemos que ir